[Musique]
dans tous les cas c'est une petite fille
qui souffre d'un polyhandicap
lorsqu'elle est né on ne savait pas
qu'il ya un problème on l'a su que le
ver 6 7 mois et on a su qu'il y avait un
souci aux funérailles mais ils ont lu
que derrière le cerveau n'était pas tout
à fait symétrique et de là on est parti
alors voilà madame du bébé parfait
normal finalement vous avez un enfant on
ne sait pas si elle n'est raciste tout
seul à jour il faut savoir quand j'ai lu
qu'elle a fait déjà plusieurs tests
génétiques et il ne trouve pas ce qu'est
là tout devient compliqué moi j'ai dû
arrêter de travailler parce qu'un public
alcan beaucoup de temps par exemple
voilà l'accès à l'école c'est compliqué
c'est une bataille tous les jours alors
que l iae droit on a trouvé un centre
notamment donc en espagne à barcelone où
ils ont méthodes de avec des
kinésithérapeutes et ostéopathes et des
façons de faire qui font progresser
l'enfant voilà à être plus autonomes des
techniques on retrouve pas en france ce
qui est dommage et malheureusement c'est
pas remboursé il faut qu'on les ya
environ deux fois par an à raison de 15
jours ce qui représente d'aucun de gym
budget de 8000 euros par an mais voilà
on y est a été une fois une semaine
à moi d'être mois d'avril et on a vu
déjà la différence entre j'ai dû qu'à la
cus de force au niveau des cuisses se
tient plus sur les genoux
on connaît assez bien la famille et le
hasard a fait que quinze jours l'amant
est déconcertée parce qu'elle elle nous
a annoncé que sa petite fille n'avait
plus d'assistance au niveau de l'école
maternelle et c'est comme ça qu'on ait
découvert qu'à la bonne petite fille qui
était handicapée
donc il ya une solidarité qui s'est mise
en place l'année dernière et on a
souhaité en tant que sportif et être
solidaire et avec la famille de leur
donner un petit coup de pouce et en le
petit coup de pouce financier
on a pensé mettre en place c était donc
de mettre en place une course donc on ne
souhaitait aider la famille et puis leur
montrer un peu
[Musique]
d'empathie de façon à ce qu'il ne se
sent pas seul face à ce trouble
mais on connaît tout particulièrement la
famille d'angelica l'on prend l'aspect t
j'aurais exprimer notre solidarité
c'est de ces courses et de récupérer des
fonds donc on a choisi de constituer une
cagnotte
on a essayé de mobiliser un maximum de
personnes par le biais de flyers c'est
tout ça et les personnes qu'on veut
venir et apporter des dons on aimerait 2
boire une participation plus important
[Musique]